Sadie's in Lexington Kentucky hi Sadie
how are you okay thanks for taking my
call
sure what's up me and my husband we've
been talking and we where we live
there's a house flat beside us and it's
on the market it's about eighty four
thousand and it set it up like right
against us and you have a fence
separating us but we have been talking
about buying my house and you don't
think I'm crazy but we didn't want to
keep it we just wanted to tear it down
and flatten out throwing it maybe put a
pool there and we live in town so we
kind of live on a busy street 50 but we
were just afraid if somebody bought that
house and when they moved into it they
would kind of run it down and make all
property go down but I have heard you
talk about kind of over building up the
neighborhood like you don't want to make
your house you know way more valuable
than the other homes in the neighborhood
so I was a little wimp not when you
bought your home was the house there
yeah and you weren't worried about it
them well no but we said true so we all
went a little bit more space you have
any $4,000 well that's that's what I was
wanting to ask you yes we have it but
I'm concerned about should would I get
more should I invest that which we
already are investing or do you think
that we're financially capable of buying
this is your house paid off it is very
good what's your household income it's
between 95 and a hundred how much do you
have saved not in retirement 130,000
okay cool okay and so here's the thing
basically you're going to lose money on
this transaction in order to get buffer
zone okay because here if we take that
house and tear it down and we put a pool
there it does not add eighty four
thousand dollars in
you to your home does it come my husband
said yeah and so you're going to lose
money on the transaction Brian but
that's okay if you're willing to do that
you've got you can afford it you've got
the money and you're gonna just lose
money so what do we do Lots in the
neighborhood sell for if you want to put
a blank lot with no house on it on the
market next door to you that lot what
would it sell for what's the dirt work
probably 2025
okay all right so we know we know later
on you could sell it for per 30 or 40 so
you're gonna lose 15 grand plus the cost
of the pool it'll go up in value but
you're gonna lose somewhere around 50
grand on the transaction depending on
when you sell it someday hmm what would
you do would you invest that money or
would you do like if we didn't plan on
I'm 33 my husband's 36 if we didn't ever
plan on moving which I know you really
can't say that because you don't really
know what the future holds but what
would you do
given your net worth I wouldn't lose 50
grand today you have a hundred if you if
you told me at a million three hundred
thousand in the account instead of a
hundred and thirty thousand I might do
it okay
but basically what you're buying is
peace of mind in space you're not buying
an investment there's no investment
return on this it's a loss and so you're
paying you're paying for the peace of
mind of nobody being next to you and the
opportunity to put a pool in and have an
expanded yard and so forth and that's
okay to do the house that I live in
I bought the adjacent 20 acres for that
reason now that I paid I paid price I
pay dirt price for it whereas I just
paid my dirt I didn't tear down a house
and someday I can sell it and it'll go
have gone up in value so at least we'll
go up in value but I didn't buy it as an
investment I bought it so there are more
trees between me and people that's why I
bought it would you do it with the net
worth like six hundred fifty thousand
well that's your net worth that includes
the value of your home and your in your
floor and Kay's in your 33 yeah
you know it's it's okay the question is
do you guys want to lose let's just say
you're gonna lose fifty thousand bucks
you're just going to write a check and
but what out the car window as you drive
down the interstate for 50 grand in
order to have this peace of mind if you
guys can get there to where you're
comfortable doing that emotionally then
that tells you if you can do it or not
okay it's it is throw it's a throwaway
money it's not an investment decision
it's a lifestyle decision the same thing
could be said let's say this let's say
that you desired one of your great
desires in life was to go on a cruise
and take your mother and father and his
mother and father and you were gonna go
on a cruise that was three weeks long
and it was fifty thousand bucks for the
three couples okay you can afford to do
that it's well you might not want to go
with them but feeling scenario here I
messed up the point is can you afford to
consume instead of invest fifty grand
yeah you probably can do you want to at
this stage I kind of doubt it
financially speaking I kind of wouldn't
but if you really you know if you really
really really really really want to do
it then do it you know it's not a big
deal and I I um I own several of my own
several Lots adjacent to properties that
I live in you know my lake house I
bought adjacent Lots to that too same
thing just to keep just give me a
distance between people and me I like
people but I like them when I want to
like them instead of knocking on my door
4:00 in the morning and so you know that
kind of stuff so anyway the it's that
that the same things I'm concerned
you've got there somebody gonna move in
next door and trash the place and then
you got a you know you got some goober
hillbilly living next to you or
something you know you just you got a
problem with that so you got to think
through that and is it worth 50 grand
it's more worth 50 grand to you than it
is your eyes
and I can tell that from talking to you
and so but you cannot call it an
investment you call it consumption
because I think we've established this
transaction loses money so are you going
to consume some money the money's you
likely never coming back the tune of
about 50,000 bucks give or take here in
order to just have this buffer and is
that worth that to you I'd be more
tempted to just move then I wouldn't do
that but it's up to you you can do
whatever you want to do good questions
an interesting discussion thanks for the
call you know that's one thing you do
want that I see I'm as I meet wealthy
people it's one thing they do they do
what she was doing she was very wise
because she's asking a question she
realizes it's an emotional decision and
she's trying to work through it
mathematically and emotionally it's good
to do both and it's okay to do something
on an emotional basis just admit it
don't act like you were smart to say I
wanted to do it shut up and just admit
it and that's called enjoying some of
your wealth
you're just admitting it you're just
going I just want to do it shut up no
other reason and that's a good enough
reason if you can afford to write the
check this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]